Batman V Superman dawn of Justice is a
movie that's finally being released in
theaters and I finally got to see it
with my eyes after years of anticipation
before they even announced this movie I
was anticipating the idea of a movie
like this I remember back in like 2001
seeing this as an upcoming release on
Yahoo movies calm and thanks to Zach
Snyder we can finally feast on this
movie with our eyes but is it any good
there's a lot of controversy around
Superman he's an alien he caused a lot
of destruction at the end of Man of
Steel Bruce Wayne aka Batman is not very
comfortable with this because many
people he cared for died that day as
well as other countless innocents so he
is ready to take Superman out so these
two heavyweights are pitted against each
other while Lex Luthor is also in town
played by Jesse Eisenberg who has a very
elaborate and evil scheme no surprise
there there are things I love about this
movie and some things that I do not love
let's start with the things I love first
off Ben Affleck killed it as Batman this
guy was phenomenal as Bruce Wayne /
Batman Bruce Wayne was interesting Bruce
Wayne was investing I cared about him I
was behind him I understood why he
disliked Superman Batman was a badass he
looked incredible this is my favorite
on-screen Batman costume we've had I do
have one problem with Batman though and
I'm going to get into that in a minute
but overall the character of Batman in
this movie his portrayal his badassery
batfleck man you proved all the
naysayers wrong you were fantastic in
this movie as I said you would be three
years ago when this was first announced
I was one of the only people it was like
don't kill me I think you'll be okay
henry cavill is just fine as superman i
wouldn't say he's amazing I don't think
he surpasses Christopher Reeve in any
way in this film but as the character he
works for me gal gadot or gal gadot
fantastic as Wonder Woman her appearance
in this movie is brief but it is
definitely crowd pleasing a lot of
people were very excited to see her show
up myself included the fight oh my god
it's fantastic it felt like Dark Knight
Returns a leap from the page onto the
screen I loved it it was amazing great
great action in fact the majority of the
action in this movie fantastic this is a
really pretty movie this is a really
good-looking movie it's also a mess
Batman V
man has a lot of problems and most of
them are narrative and story based every
Zack Snyder movie looks amazing but he
has a hard time balancing story with
amazing visuals and Batman V Superman is
kind of a beautiful gigantic splat of
Awesomeness and unfortunately not all of
these elements are very cohesive my
biggest issue with this movie is the
fact that it feels like two different
movies the first half is this very
mature almost political thriller there's
all this controversy surrounding
Superman does he have a place on this
earth is he welcomed we have Bruce Wayne
attempting to figure out secrets about
other people that will eventually be in
the Justice League and it feels very
realistic and very grounded and then all
of a sudden the film blows it's
metaphorical load and every single thing
you could possibly think of suddenly
appears in this movie and becomes a
gigantic science-fiction extravaganza
there are so many little elements I'm
going to get into with my spoiler video
I'm doing with John the flick pic he
came with me to see the film that video
is going to be up later this weekend
that just didn't make sense
towards the last half of the movie the
film has a really hard time making Lois
Lane relevant she has an object she gets
rid of an object then she has to get the
object again then she gets trapped and
she's a damsel in distress and she goes
back and forth between being a character
that deserves to be in this movie and a
character that's just there because
she's Lois Lane at one point in time
Wonder Woman gets a very important email
from Bruce Wayne and the subject line of
this email should have just said Justice
League set up it is the most lazy
shoo-in of these characters I've seen I
couldn't believe it I mean certain
people are going to be really excited
when they see certain things but it's so
forced it just feels so forced do you
remember Avengers age of Ultron pretty
fun movie over all right well we're
about that thor ragnarok tie-in where he
goes to that pool that felt really out
of place right well they needed that
because the studio said hey you got to
put that in the movie didn't really feel
like it belong in the movie right right
what's the best superhero movie of the
past couple years in my opinion it's
Deadpool why was Deadpool so great
because they could just make one great
entertaining movie that wasn't so overly
concerned with setting up a world or a
universe
Deadpool could be a great movie because
it didn't have to set up a whole bunch
of other movies now we all want Deadpool
too because we loved it and that's what
filmmakers are forgetting about nowadays
films like the amazing spider-man 2 that
movie was so concerned about setting up
the sinister six that have forgot to be
a good movie this film is so concerned
with the necessary puzzle pieces for the
eventual Justice League that this film
forgot to just be a great standalone
movie it was almost like the first half
was trying to be a great standalone
movie and then towards the end they just
have to shoehorn in all of these little
elements to make us feel like yeah
there's going to be a Justice League and
the script just couldn't balance it it
was so so sloppy let's talk about that
one element of Batman that really let me
down this guy shooting people left and
right
he's blowing people up he's laying down
machine-gun fire on all kinds of people
what and it's not just the dream
sequences in this film in which he kills
people because I okay it's a dream
sequence whatever in real life this
dude's mowing people down blowing people
away I don't know what they were
thinking they completely took away the
moral dilemma of the character of Batman
Batman was always right on the edge of
becoming a criminal but villains like
the Joker constantly forced him to ride
that edge and that was enthralling and
if you want go ahead and quote comic
book issues in which this happened and
while Chris you'd never read this comic
book or well Chris you don't know about
that story arc there's never a scene in
this film where Jeremy Irons is Alfred
who by the way is fantastic sits down
with Batman and goes look you're going
too far yeah well they killed Robin and
I have no choice like if they had a
scene like that then I would have been
able to get behind it but there's never
an attempt to explain why Batman has
completely thrown the morals of his
entire code out of the window he just
kills people now despite the fact that I
loved Batman in this movie I really
hated they never once attempted to
explain why his moral code has
completely been forgotten about now
about Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor well
not since Ben Affleck being cast as
Batman has there been such an uproar
over a casting choice and it might have
been well deserved he was okay he was
all
right I don't know if it worked for me
he was a little insane he went the
insane route he reminded me of Nicholas
Cage in the movie matchstick men if you
ever seen the movie matchstick men
Nicolas Cage plays an OCD con artist who
has a bit of a twitch every once in a
while he's like oh and there's a lot of
moments like that in this film
I mean moments where Lex Luthor will be
standing there and he'll just kind of go
I like Jesse Eisenberg there were some
scenes where I thought he did a very
good job there were some scenes where I
thought he was very menacing but overall
the performance was fine and it could
have been a lot better and I'm not sure
if the insane
twitchy OCD route was really the best
choice Batman V Superman is a very
pretty movie it has some really good
performances it has some really
interesting elements it has some really
cool action but unfortunately if you saw
that one trailer you know the trailer
I'm talking about you really have seen
the entire film and there's really no
more surprises left the film makes a
really cool choice but then the film
backs down from that choice and that
also bugged me there's a lot that could
have been great about this movie but it
is a mess and trust me I wanted to love
it I used to run around the house with
my underwear on on the outside of my
pants and a towel wrapped around my neck
because I was Superman damn it and I
love Batman
I should have been crying throughout
this entire film but unfortunately it is
a bit of a mess I would recommend seeing
it though as a comic book movie fan I
love these characters Batman is awesome
in it I'm gonna give Batman V Superman
dawn of Justice a C+
trust me I'm really disappointed in
saying that but I'm not saying it's
awful there's this thing with the
internet where you have to love it or
you have to hate it I'm very
middle-of-the-road I'm very conflicted
on this movie there are things I love
about it the things I dislike about it
guys those are my thoughts on Batman V
Superman spoiler video coming this
weekend also please look forward to my
hilarious 'ti this Sunday because it's
going to be something very special I am
going to review some of my childhood
films because they're not that great and
it's time for me to make fun of myself I
think I've made fun of other people's
movies enough let's turn the sights on
me a little bit you guys have asked me
to
show you my Indiana Jones movies for
quite some time I'm gonna do that except
I'm gonna review them I'm gonna show you
clips I'm gonna make fun of myself it's
gonna be tons of fun that's gonna be
Sunday also thank you so much to
everyone who's bought my book I'm
serious I I can't believe it people have
been sending me photos of themselves in
the bookstore and it's brought a tear to
my eye I am so grateful thank you so
much for doing that guys and thank you
to the amazing people who sent my wife
and I stuff in our p.o box this
incredible painting really touched our
hearts this Superman figure back there
that Wonder Woman season you guys are
amazing thank you so much I don't even
know what to say I'm blown away by your
kindness and generosity thank you you
guys are the best
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck man eyes